tina nigella lawson's here i know in
lockdown your
your daughters have become sort of
gourmet chefs yes they've prepared some
dinners for us
my husband's a good cook but he got a
break from them a couple times we did
some themed dinners
um since we're all about to lock down
again i i recommend these uh
they did um we did one we did like a
victorian night dinner
we did a a mexican
fiesta and we did the best one though
was they did an airline dinner for us
up all the chairs it was a dream
actually because they said all the
chairs like fit
one behind the other no one facing
anyone else
like warmed nuts on a tray and um
and and they didn't children don't
understand how much wine is too much
wine
it's a poor i'm an adult
filled to surface tension you've sent
some pictures of this evening
i mean they really went all out everyone
had a window seat
yeah everyone's got a window seat right
we put a picture of an airplane window
on the tv
they made stewardess costumes for
themselves oh let's see the stewardess
costumes
[Applause]
and then is this is this the same
evening where they put the reading
materials
in the back of the magazines they shove
magazines in the back
we put headphones on like a plane and we
ate in in
silence and it was the best night we had
in seven weeks
i think everyone's going to be doing
this it's the way
forward it's the way forward
[Music]